[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
federal authorities track and arrest
capitol riders across the country
as new security threats emerge the
wrongdoers
will be held responsible a convicted
rapist is sentenced for a cold case but
this isn't case closed yet
probably some of the most horrific facts
i've read in a long time
and the only one woman on death row is
executed after the nation's highest
court overturned her appeals
plus should an accused murderer get
state money to help pay for his defense
the latest legal battle in the
disappearance of a georgia beauty queen
they're looking for experts and they
don't have money for experts
long crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
the nation's top prosecutor is speaking
out against the capital insurrection
lives were lost the storming of the
capitol
was an intolerable shocking and tragic
episode in our nation's history
some charges were brought the very next
day
those efforts remain active and will
continue until
justice is done in the last week
more than 70 individuals have been
criminally charged
we've opened more than 170
investigations
the fbi has gathered more than a hundred
thousand digital tips from the public
and there is a lot more to come the
department of justice
will seek to hold any violators
accountable to the fullest
extent of the law
those comments come nearly a week after
video of the deadly assault was
broadcast around the world
glider storm the steps of the capitol
building on january 6.
a mob seen pushing towards the front
doors as an officer's shield is taken
let's go this video taken by a group
called status quo
appears to show the mob using pepper
spray and tasers
[Music]
one officer becoming trapped between the
doors
the group continuing to push forward
the officer now without his mask is
bleeding and screaming for help
dc's acting police chief says that the
officer was able to free himself
and is recovering
[Music]
it makes me sick to my stomach to see
that that video and that officer
obviously he was afraid for his life
federal authorities continue to make
arrests including a man seen wearing a
camp auschwitz shirt
while storming the capitol building
the initial charges everyone's familiar
with the the zip tie guys the munchalls
and uh the brocks that were rested on
this on the
on the house floor with zip ties rifling
through the house floor
people are familiar with online they see
the uh barnett's and johnson's who were
literally rifling through pelosi's
office and stealing items stealing
materials male and sometimes even
personal mementos we're looking at
significant felony cases tied to
sedition and conspiracy and it's going
to come into laser focus i think over
the next
weeks and days and i think people are
going to be shocked with some of the
egregious contact that happened within
the capitol
lawn crime expert and veteran swat team
member lisa lockwood
says authorities are not only looking
into the actions of the rioters
but also the actions of law enforcement
well the first thing they're looking at
is the officers who were actually on
duty that day
so they're in uniform and it's easy to
identify they can take a tally to find
out who was there
what part of the perimeter were they in
charge of and they actually see the
video on the inside
we know that officer goodman was the
hero of the event who actually
led the protesters through the building
to get them away from the senate
entrance
so that was a phenomenal act of courage
and thinking on his feet
in that instance the two that are
suspended that's my understanding
is because they were leading protesters
around to another entrance
we don't know the full story were they
leading them around to get them away as
well
we don't know unfortunately at this
stage of the game because it is an
ongoing investigation but they're using
all the tools that they have
hundred thousand pieces of digital
evidence has come in so it's going to
take quite a bit of time to scour
through all of it
joining me now is criminal defense
attorney gigi gonzalez along with terry
austin
gg acting u.s attorney general rosen
said charges so far
are placeholders for larger crimes can
you talk about felony murder
one of those charges that he said is on
the table
felony murder is a killing that occurs
during the commission of a violent crime
and here we saw the deaths of multiple
people including an
officer during the planned attack on the
capital
by armed insurrectionists uh anybody
that was involved in storming this
capital is going to be facing potential
felony murder charges
as these killings and murders were
reasonably
uh foreseeable under the circumstances
now terry these cases are not all being
heard in d.c but instead
are spread throughout the country in
different federal courts
why well brian just to be clear
there will be federal charges filed in
d.c district court along with state
charges filed in d.c
superior court but as you correctly
state attorneys in
ohio minnesota kentucky and other states
they've said and they've pledged to
prosecute
anyone who traveled from their areas to
take part in these
riots and right now more than 160 case
files
have been opened and 70 people have been
charged so far
and i definitely think that we're going
to get some convictions
all right so that makes sense it might
not just be where they ended up but
where they travel from where that case
may start
thank you both and now for a piece of
good news before we go to the break
the family of a teenage girl who escaped
her kidnapper
after he killed her parents two years
ago says she's happy and doing well
jamie closs was just 13 years old when
she fled a wisconsin cabin following 88
days of captivity
in january 2019. her captor jake
patterson
pled guilty to killing the teen's
parents james and denise kloss
and forcing jaime away in his car
patterson is currently serving a life
sentence
jamie's aunt and legal guardian pro
posted on facebook that she's enjoying
dance
school activities and is surrounded by
lots of loved ones
still ahead on law and crime daily for
the first time in 70 years the federal
government executes a female inmate
but first a kentucky rapist who evaded
capture for 40 years
has finally been sentenced but does the
time fit the crime
[Music]
[Music]
a man who admitted to kidnapping and
raping a woman in 1978
is sentenced as detectives in kentucky
try to link him to more crimes
angela libby joins us with more on
michael take's case and her exclusive
interview
with a woman who survived the attack
yeah brian michael tate was sentenced on
those three charges he pleaded guilty to
they were kidnapping sodomy and rape
and that woman thankfully survived as
we've been discussing
this week now detectives in boone county
kentucky interviewed tate in november of
2019 about that attack
and at the time they said he actually
admitted to committing
multiple rapes in several states those
detectives went to tate
after looking at cases that had
similarities to an
unsolved 1976 homicide
they resubmitted a fingerprint from the
rape case and it came back to michael
tate
he said very little during his
sentencing hearing
this was a case um early on
we had been working with the
commonwealth to resolve and i know that
this recommendation was made to you
after due consideration
we believe that given the complexities
of prosecuting a 40-year-old
offense that this resolution is in the
best interest the commonwealth
the victim is in agreement we'd ask the
court to impose the agreed upon
sentence uh mr tate
i'm going to accept the recommendation
of the commonwealth i've got to say
though it's probably some of the most
horrific
facts i've read in a long time
um so other than
the fact that it will bring comfort to
the victim that she doesn't have to
appear
in court and that she doesn't have to go
through some of these things again
i i assume that you've read her
statement
yes i am yeah and well i understand in
your statement as well you talk about
remorse but
and in any event really horrific
horrific
acts completely changed her life
so it wasn't just an act or several acts
and a night it was something that pretty
much
deteriorated her joy of life
and so in other circumstances i would
reject this
but given these circumstances i will
accept it
and the judge really seemed to question
and seem to be kind of unhappy about
that 12-year sentence but the victim is
you heard
she actually agreed to that she really
didn't want to return to kentucky she
lives several states away now
and she also says that she hopes that
michael tate will eventually confess to
crimes that he told her
he committed
and that's what was most important to me
because i got
through it and survived him i just
i feel for the little if there's girls
and young women out there that have been
murdered
and they don't know what happened to him
that's what really bothers me so i wish
he would admit to that
and i'll be praying for that every day
before he passes and maybe he'll do it
and michael tate is 78 years old he will
be about 90 years old when he gets out
of prison
the survivor said yesterday that she was
happy after the sentencing and with
everything she's been through
through the years living with this she
says this makes her breathe a little bit
easier
brian thanks angina now is there any
progress
on the detectives matching up the rapes
tate confessed to
you know they're working on that they
said multiple rapes in multiple states
they have worked with an fbi task force
officer
to help piece some of these together and
match the confessions with the crimes
they are still working on that they
haven't been able to match those other
confessions
with other cases they're hoping people
will actually come forward
and that could aid them in solving some
of the cases
now terry what do you think about the 12
year sentence for such a heinous crime
the judge seemed a little taken aback by
the sentence
she did seem taken aback and i think it
is a short amount of time but you know
as the party said it's a 40 year old
case
and he is 78 years old and you know
research shows that each year in prison
takes two years off of his life
his average expectancy is 75
years so with a 12-year sentence it
means that he will likely die
in prison and couple that with the fact
that the victim doesn't have to stand
the scrutiny of a trial
i think it is a reasonable result
even though it is a horrendous crime
now gigi now that we understand his mo
through his confession
not only of this case but in other
crimes do you anticipate that we
possibly hear
of other cases that he didn't confess to
being connected to him
very likely in his confession he said
that he
uh targeted uh young women between the
ages of 14 and 16 years old throughout
the south and the east coast uh all
detectives have to do
is look throughout those cold cases
where we had
victims uh that were murdered by um and
were raped and sodomized uh
look for his dna at those crime scenes
to potentially connect him to those as
well
all right terry and jeanette and gigi
thank you very much for your input on
the case
coming up on law and crime daily the
bold request from one of the defendants
in the murder of a georgia beauty queen
plus
why the only female federal death row
inmate was put to death
amid calls for a stay of execution
[Music]
the federal government executed the
first female inmate in nearly 70 years
tuesday night law and crimes terry
austin explains how last-minute appeals
were overturned
brian 52-year-old lisa montgomery died
by lethal injection
following a temporary stay and amid
calls that her life should be spared
montgomery was pronounced dead at
approximately 1 31
a.m she was convicted for the 2004
murder of bobby joe stinnett in which
she cuts the net's baby
from her womb and tried to pass the baby
off as her
own a district court had stayed the
execution
but the supreme court overturned that
ruling in a late night opinion
several organizations advocated for
montgomery's sentence to be commuted
saying she suffered from mental illness
but a lot of what the government points
to as being premeditated
is often actually a symptom of mental
illness
um as somebody who is forcibly
sterilized
lisa was fixated on having children and
so some of the
evidence that the government has pointed
to is indicating that this
was a premeditated and very well thought
through crime
was actually a symptom of lisa's mental
illness and
of her trauma
former michigan governor rick snyder and
several ex-officials according to
reports
will soon be indicted for their role in
the flint water crisis
problems with flint's water can be
traced back to 2014
when the city's water supply was
switched by city and state officials
in an effort to cut costs the decision
exposed residents to high levels of lead
12 people died and over 80 residents
became ill
from legionnaires disease caused by the
toxic water
governor snyder apologized for the
crisis in 2016.
snyder's attorney calls the reports
meritless and a political escapade
could a tool used to fight fires
actually be harmful to first responders
chief investigative correspondent brian
ross has the report
thanks brian coming up this week on
brian ross investigates
january is firefighters cancer awareness
month
and now scientists and some firefighters
are sounding the alarm
about a chemical used to waterproof
their turnout gear
could it be a risk to the firefighters
there's a
strong correlation between the c8 form
of this chemical and two types of cancer
testicular cancer and kidney cancer
but most firefighters aren't aware that
they shouldn't be handling this stuff
and that's that's the issue the industry
says the amount of chemical used is not
enough to warrant concern
other scientists disagree we'll talk
about it this week
on brian ross investigates back to you
brian
when we come back on updating the murder
of a georgia beauty queen
one of the defendants seeks the state's
help with his representation
does his request stand a chance find out
next
one of the defendants charged in the
murder of a georgia beauty queen is
asking for state funds to help in his
representation
teacher and pageant competitor tara
grinstead died in october 2005.
alleged killer ryan duke wants the
georgia supreme court to allow him to
use government money to hire
investigators and experts on his behalf
he's being represented by private
attorneys for his upcoming trial
but they're working for free
co-defendant beau dukes pled guilty in
2019
to helping him get rid of the body the
state's highest court first heard ryan
duke's argument
in 2019. now they say they have
jurisdiction over the case and are
considering the defense's request
one more time
our opinion is that mr uh duke did not
sacrifice or waive his right to counsel
of his choice
uh simply uh because he elected to use
pro bono counsel
if you look at the plain language of the
statute it certainly doesn't exclude pro
bono attorneys
and if you look at the context of the
language where other resources is
contained
it follows right after uh the definition
of indigency which is
someone who makes less than 150 of the
poverty guidelines so if you read those
two pieces together clearly
the intent of other resources is other
financial resources which mr duke
admittedly does not have in the state
has not contended he has
the only contention here is that because
he's able to get a free lawyer
that that somehow constitutes other
resources
during the hearing prosecutors said that
the pro bono attorneys should be
sufficient
and duke shouldn't qualify for state
money
he was represented by poet defender for
i believe
upwards of 15 months however at the time
that miss merchant reapplied for the
public defender services
on behalf of mr duke the local public
defender did deny
the services and indicated that
essentially that he did have other
resources which were pro bono attorneys
and so at this point he has been denied
representation as
having other resources
the justices asked the prosecutor how
does she expect the defendant to pay for
his experts
mr duke has the media attention that has
come with this case but for that
that brings no money with it it actually
i would respect
if mr duke is indigent as the trial
court said he was
by definition he does not have money for
experts the fact that he has
notoriety is not is not
monetizable at least in any way that
that our justice system recognizes
i would state that it again i would
respectfully disagree but for that
notoriety he wouldn't have these
attorneys they
heard the name this is a very difficult
argument to make and you you are telling
that the state wants the criminal
defendants to exploit their notoriety
um you know in the federal system
there's a statute that
says if defendants do that all of the
money forfeited to the victims so
but you're saying that that actually
makes somebody a source of revenue that
the state encourages
i'm not encouraging that at all i'm
saying that's what's occurred in this
case but how is he supposed to hire an
expert
um how is he supposed to hire an expert
he should have gone he would remain with
the public defenders through the ida
so represented by the merchants he has
no ability to hire an expert you would
agree
i agree gigi
do you think a private attorney working
pro bono should be able to use state
funds to represent a client
yes absolutely right now indigent
clients
they are either they get appointed a
public defender or if a public defender
is not available for whatever reason
then the court will appoint a private
attorney and they
the private attorney will bill the
county accordingly
here you've got attorneys who are
stepping in uh representing the indigent
client
at a reduced rate uh which is a benefit
to
the county and you should allow him uh
the attorneys to build the county for
the experts
and not for the attorney's fees and
right now the precedent that could be
set is
either you better be too broke or so
rich that you can afford
experts to defend yourself with
otherwise you're not going to get a fair
shake
i mean that's how it works in new york
where i practice and of course florida
where gg practices
terry how do you think the judges will
rule here
i think the judge will rule the way gigi
just said i'm in full agreement with her
they should allow for the payment of the
same expert
ryan duke would have received whether
he's pro bono whether he's
court appointed it doesn't matter
whether he represents himself because
you know that's the due process argument
gigi and terry thank you for your input
and thank you for joining us here at law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice
in america
[Music]
[Music]
you